el patio de armerías del palacio real de
madrid fue el escenario del tercer
homenaje del estado a las víctimas de
kobe 19 una llama arde en recuerdo a las
casi 109 mil personas que han fallecido
desde marzo de 2020 el evento solemne
presidido por el rey felipe sexto y
bautizado como aplauso para el recuerdo
llega cuando el país atraviesa una nueva
ola de contagios que deja además tres
veces más hospitalizados que en las
mismas fechas del año pasado y es que
como bien lo recordó la o ms hace unos
días esta pandemia está lejos de haber
terminado la variante o micro en deja
unos 30 mil contagios semanales
confirmados pero que podrían ser muchos
más ya que al haberse levantado las
medidas de seguimiento a los menores de
65 años no se contabilizan todos los
positivos que hay los aplausos además
volvieron a sonar como cada tarde
durante lo peor de la pandemia hacia los
sanitarios que aún tienen que lidiar con
las consecuencias la diferencia es que
ahora dos años y medio después estos
trabajadores están agotados pese a que
el congreso recién aprobó una ley para
acabar con la temporalidad que afecta a
cuatro de cada diez profesionales de la
salud éstos recuerdan que esta
legislación no solventa la falta de
personal a la que se ve sometido el
sector